Hello everybody welcome back to the show
it is an end of 2023 review it's the
best lessons that I've learned over the
last 12 months I did one of these a year
ago and it went down really well and I
really enjoyed the process so I figured
I'd do it again if you want to do an end
of review I have a free template which
you can actually go and do right now you
can download it and it'll help to
structure your end of 2023 review and
give you plans for 2024 you can go and
get that at Chris willll
x.com revie it's completely free you can
just copy it and fill it in and use your
notes app of choice Chris willll
x.com review all right let's get into it
first one is you should just be yourself
not because it will make you more
likable it won't but because it's only
by being yourself that you'll find
people who like you for who you really
are rather than someone you're
pretending to be that's from ginda Bogle
and this was one of the biggest
realizations of my 20s the the advantage
of doing this thing where you sort of
push off of who you really are is that
no criticism will ever fully land
because you're one degree removed from
the person who's being criticized the
disadvantage is that you're also removed
from the person who's being complimented
and if you're only playing a role you
never fully feel connected to the
successes that you have in your life any
accolades or warmth that you receive
won't resonate properly in your heart
because it's not you who's receiving it
it's the character that you're
pretending to be Al Markus said the
Persona is incapable of receiving love
it can only receive praise and this is
how you can feel alone in a crowd and
Hollow in Victory if you haven't shown
your true self to the people around you
you are inevitably going to feel
disconnected from them and the people
who would have fallen in love with the
true you will pass you by because that
person is never presented the Persona
subsumes the person this isn't the
people around you's fault either like
you need to take responsibility for this
there are reasons to fear truly showing
up but they pale in insignificance
compared to the reasons to hide away
like even if all that you want is
Success your highest point of unique
contribution involves you fully
embracing you forget the actualizing
yourself forward and offering the world
something which no one else can nval
ravikant says no one can beat you at
being you the absolute best that you can
hope for if you're playing a role is to
be the second best in the world being
someone else I did this research for a
tedex talk that I did a couple of years
ago around Salvador Daly so dar's
parents gave birth to a child about 9
months before Dary was born who was also
called Salvador and they were adamant
that he was The Reincarnation of their
Lost Child so like that was how he
entered the world which might explain
kind of why he was a bit crazy later on
in life uh when he was a child he used
to throw himself down down the stairs he
was a masochist he used to enjoy
throwing himself down the stairs he once
gave a a speech a keynote speech at the
University and he had to be wrenched out
of a deep sea diving suit that he put
himself into mid talk because he was
suffocating uh the woman that he ended
up marrying he married this lady who was
got this lady away from her marriage he
was in one so was she they both
separated came together and he literally
thought that she was his Muse that she
was like divine he immediately bought
her a castle and then sent her formal
letters of request in order for him to
be able to go and visit her in the
castle that he bought her so just super
eccentric guy but the point is that is
part and parcel of Salvador DOI if he
hadn't done all of those other things
the world would have been fundamentally
less because as brilliant as they were
Michelangelo didn't do Dary and da Vinci
didn't do Dary so had Salvador been
anything short of his his absolute
Unapologetic showing up self to the
world the world would have been
fundamentally less he would have been a
pale imitation of something or someone
else so yeah that Insight from Ginder
around you should just be yourself not
because it'll make you more likable but
because you'll actually find people who
like you for who you are rather than
someone you're pretending to be there
like 10 different reasons to do that but
I also understand that it's scary and if
you don't have confidence that who you
are when fully expose yourself as
someone that's likable it means that
well you don't want to do it but again
like having people fall in love with
some fake version of you doesn't seem
like it would be very fulfilling either
next one it's one thing to get what you
want but it's another thing to want
what's worth getting that's from Shane
parish and this is just like a really
great Insight that the danger of not
spending time working out what you want
to want can cause you no matter how hard
you work to move in the wrong direction
your life as far as I can see it should
be lived by Design not by default this
guy Kyle Ean rer explains it so well he
said uh blindly following your desires
makes you a slave to your impulses a
slave to the assumptions of those around
you the advertisements you're exposed to
and the confused chemical signals of
your body if we don't pause and ask
ourselves what we want to want we will
spend our lives focused on unhealthy
aims defined for us by others the worst
parts of ourselves we will pass these
bad assumptions about life onto our
children and loved ones we will
reinforce these boring desperate
defaults in everything and everyone we
encounter to achieve Freedom we must be
able to think for ourselves if we don't
cut to the core and program our wants
then our best case scenario is to be a
rich famous or successful slave if we
never peer into our programming then we
may end up being the cleverest rat in
the room but that's hardly worth
celebrating ating in short your default
factory settings are [__] don't follow
them people who will never actually the
people who do this are never going to
fully actualize their potential either
for happiness or for Success there's
this quote from senica where he says
they do not what they intended but what
they happen to run across so you can
imagine it's the difference between
being a a cork bobbing around in the
ocean which moves but it doesn't move
under its own Steam or with its own
desire and its own Direction and being a
boat which actually forces itself
through the environment toward a
direction that it's chosen so if you
think about it that your desires Define
your own path of least
resistance what you want is to be able
to arrive at a place where the things
that you want are the things that you
want to want and that's why desires are
important through deliberate training
that at first feels tedious you can
eventually arrive at that place where
what you want is what you want to want
and that's where the life should be
lived by Design not default things comes
in because your default factory settings
send you off into like such strange
sub-optimized areas of life like
whatever the current societal Norms are
or the way that you've dealt with past
trauma or what your parents made you
think that you were supposed to like all
of those things aren't things that you
necessarily want to want they could be
but you need to get a like stress test
this and work out whether or not it is
so yes your life should be lived by
Design not default it's one thing to get
what you want but it's another thing to
want what's worth getting next one toxic
compassion so this is one of my
favorites by the way everyone gave me
[__] the last time that I was doing a
solo episode because I was drinking just
FYI I drink on the normal episodes as
well I'm talking for an hour I need some
sort of moisture and and hydration in my
face difference is I can usually mute
the mic and do it while the other
person's talking when it's a two-way
episode so forgive me that I need to be
hydrated but someone accused me of not
having any Dr it was it's obvious that
there's nothing in the can it's like why
would I be lifting this to my face if
there wasn't anything in it anyway I
will be drinking throughout solo
episodes I apologize I'll try and drink
quietly there we are toxic compassion
toxic compassion is this really I love
it I I it's one of the coolest ideas
that I've come up with this year and I
was looking for a name for this
phenomenon that I'd seen for so long and
I cycled through what was it like the
shallow Pond of empathy uh uh [__]
like Satan like the inverse of Satan's
love like all sorts of weird and
wonderful other words and then toxic
compassion just came to me and I thought
that's that's it so toxic compassion is
the prioritization of short-term
emotional Comfort over everything else
over truth reality actual long-term
outcomes flourishing everything it
optimizes for looking good rather than
doing good and this is seen in much of
popular culture as the desirable Fair
empathetic thing to do and it's
everywhere people would rather claim
that body fat has no bearing on health
and mortality outcomes to avoid making
overweight people feel upset even if
this causes them to literally die sooner
or have a worse quality of life over the
long run parents would rather allow
children to play computer games or watch
screens and access social media every
night instead of dealing with the
discomfort of taking it away from them
even if it ruins their brain development
social skills and self-esteem people
would rather say that children growing
up in single parent households suffer no
worse outcomes than those from two
parent homes even if this misleads
parents children and teachers about why
kids behave the way that they do
campaigners would soon shout defund the
police as a response to what they
perceive as the unfair treatment of
criminals even if this results in more
crimes being committed against people
from Minority backgrounds due to the
abandonment of police officers from
those very areas and Elon Musk recently
responded to some criticism about his
political alignment and contribution to
climate change and skepticism of it I
think and then he identified how big of
a shift Tesla had caused in the electric
vehicle market and the downstream impact
of that on the environment he said he's
done more for the climate than any other
human in history and this quote from him
is what I care about is the reality of
goodness not the perception of it and
what I see all over the place is people
who care about looking good while doing
evil the important trade-off with all of
those examples including Elon is between
appearing good and actually doing good
so telling people what they want to hear
giving them immediate gratification and
avoiding saying anything that could
cause distress prioritizes the former of
looking good over the latter of doing
good and the net effect is usually
wildly negative it's it's like a toddler
who wants to eat ice cream every night
sure that might be what they want in the
moment but it's going to be wildly
unhealthy over the long term and I asked
Jordan Peterson about this on our last
episode and he said that's exactly what
the edle situation is it's the
prioritization of short-term emotional
Comfort over long-term thriving it's
going to hurt now but the long-term
consequences are positive if you give up
your children to the world you will keep
them and this Prospect of appearing bad
while doing good is obviously not very
enticing like you get all of the
negatives up front of not appearing like
somebody that cares and is empathetic
even though yeah sure enough down the
line people will benefit from it but
you're going to be lambasted and
criticized and and and seem like someone
who doesn't care in the moment and the
opposite of this is performative empathy
saying whatever is required to look good
even if you don't actually care and on
the internet the gap between words and
actions has never been bigger you can be
the least virtuous the meanest most
dishonest human on earth but if you say
the right things if your thumbs
literally hit the right buttons on a
screen you look like a saint and no one
ever stress tests the world words coming
out of your mouths so it means that
appearing good actually becomes more
important than doing good so this the
incentive of performative empathy kind
of creates the basis for toxic
compassion as as a trend you know
posting about mistreated groups is more
incentivized than actually helping
mistreated groups it's all of the people
who have put a flag in their bio but
have never actually donated to a charity
and this isn't me saying that you can't
do good whilst also talking about it
it's that many maybe even most of the
people who prze about how virtuous and
caring they are and about how it's
everyone else who is evil and done
caring and the enemy are allowing their
morality to stand on the shoulders of
limited scrutiny Peterson said it's like
look how good I am well if the look at
comes before the how good I am it really
WS hav it with the claim I I think the
the big lesson here is just beware the
people who prioritize saying good things
because they might not actually be doing
good things this balance between what is
it that you're saying how does it look
and what are you doing what are the
outcomes I see it everywhere and this
idea of toxic compassion I think is it's
useful it's a useful frame and I don't
know everyone kind of has this in the
back of their mind there's a degree of
skepticism and scrutiny about anyone
that says something good online but we
all know that there are huge huge swats
of people who are probably not that nice
probably not that caring probably don't
really give a [__] about whatever the
topic or movement is that they're
getting behind or supposed to be a a
front runner for lizo lizo supposed to
be this Paragon of virtue and supporting
these girls and giving them a platform
behind the scenes she's body shaming her
dancers she's forcing them to go on
fasts when she isn't making them eat
bananas out of the vaginas of Amsterdam
strippers Ellen degenerous Jimmy Fallon
you know allegedly allegedly all of
these people that out front of these
sort of cutesy nicy nicy people and
behind the scenes the staff that have
worked with them who know them best say
that they're tyrants super mean so yeah
I just
think there's not really a way around
this I'd be interested to try and think
of a way around this because what you
supposed to do it's easier to see
someone's words than it is their deeds
Deeds can be faked as
well and there's always going to be an
incentive for people to just say the
right thing again say an increasingly
complex or um convincing set of mouth
face thumb noises so that you believe
whatever it is but yeah I I thought
toxic compassion one of the probably top
five memes that's that's come out of
this year all right next one this is
Elon as well and this was on Lex's show
such a good Insight you know you look at
on as somebody who is um probably quite
admired by lots of people on the
internet wealth status influence all the
rest of it and Lex asked how he was
doing and sort of what it's like to be
him and Elon replied my mind is a storm
I don't think most people would want to
be me they may think they would want to
be me but they don't they don't know
they don't understand and this is why
jealousy is a stupid emotion in fact
Envy is one of the it's the only one of
the the seven deadly sins which doesn't
actually feel good think about that so
Naval says about jealousy I realized
that all of these people I was jealous
of I couldn't just cherry-pick and
choose little aspects of their life I
couldn't say I want his body I want her
money I want his personality you have to
be that person you actually want to be
that person with all of their reactions
their desires their family their
happiness level their outlook on life
their self-image if you're not willing
to do a wholesale 24/7 100% swap with
who who that person is then there is no
point in being jealous it seems obvious
but it's so counterintuitive to how we
all relate to the people that we admire
we look at humans that we are jealous of
as ubiquitous successes this sort of
brilliant collage worthy of lifewide
admiration and envy and we presumed that
we could add the elements of their life
which we love like taking clothes off a
rail but that's not how life works the
outfit that you are imagining trying on
is is head to toe not pick and shoes
it's a onesie right not an alak cart
wardrobe the price that you would need
to pay to be the P the person or the
people that you admire is often one that
you wouldn't fot the bill for and this
is what we're seeing with Elon as well
that this dude who's you know created
potentially one of the coolest most
Innovative cars in history with the
cybertruck that just got released a
couple of weeks ago and he's on stage
doing like weird robot dances in
Japan sending Rockets to Mars you're
trying to make Humanity a multiplanetary
species like you look at him and you
think well he must if he doesn't have it
sorted if he's not the guy who is one of
the wealthiest people on the planet
bought Twitter just basically for fun
well he's saying my mind is a storm
people think they would want to be me
but they don't they don't know they
don't understand like that
is the ground truth reality of his life
and yeah I just think again for
reminding us that people who outwardly
have lots of things going for them
inwardly can be suffering and have
completely unadmirable uh undesirable
internal States in fact perhaps the
people who are most desirable externally
May correlate with being the least
desirable internally it gives us a
couple of things first off it can give
us a little bit of empathy that success
outwardly doesn't fix all problems
internally and it helps us to stop
accusing things of being first world
problems a lot and secondly it helps us
realize that just because someone does
have lots of things outwardly that we
might desire that doesn't mean that we
should actually be in any way envious of
them or that they're a particularly good
person doesn't mean that they're good
just because they're successful speaking
of that there was this I've quoted it a
lot this year so sorry if you've heard
this one before but the documentary
following Lewis Capaldi around as he's
going through this big change in
scrutiny and status and fame does his
first album which goes Super well and
then he's got to make the second one and
he develops a nervous tick I think it's
Tourette's he sort of starts doing this
a lot and it's not good you know I've
seen videos of him in front of however
many tens of thousands of people at
glastenbury unable to sing because of
our nervous is and I think this was only
this summer so the documentary tries to
finish on like a an uplifting Arc where
he's like and I went and did some yoga
and breath work and now my [__]
mental health is under control but it's
not it's not under control this guy is
still as one of the most successful
breakout artists of The Last 5 Years
this dude is still failing on the
biggest stages that there are to fail on
you know like glastenbury it doesn't get
much big maybe it was like leads
festival or reading or something instead
but this guy is struggling really really
struggling and he's got this line in the
documentary where he turns to the camera
and he says Fame doesn't change you it
just changes everyone around you and
again like I have Niche Fame I have
Micro Micro influencer Niche Fame but
there is something disconcerting and
it's hard dude it's so hard to talk
about this I spoke about this at one of
the live q&as it's really difficult to
talk about this on the internet without
being accused of being full of yourself
or or having a massive ego or thinking
that you're more important than you are
or complaining about first world
problems don't you know about how hard
people are the people have got it you
just get to Dick about on a on a camera
and a microphone and have all of this
stuff I get it all of those things I get
it but if you genuinely are interested
in finding out what it feels like to go
from completely as normal person as
possible to still unbelievably normal
person with micro influence and Niche
Fame like I'm telling you that this is
how it feels or at least this is how it
feels to me which is it's disconcerting
like it's it's very nice and it's
flattering but imagine that you woke up
tomorrow and everybody immediately
started treating you differently and you
didn't understand why because you see
yourself as the same person and maybe
even the things that you do are the same
nothing's changed Lis Capaldi singing
the same songs that he was singing when
he was 17 18 years old in working men's
pubs around Scotland those were the same
songs that he then belted out across a
global tour billions and billions of
streams Fame doesn't change you it just
changes everyone around you you haven't
even changed the thing that you're doing
and everybody else refers to you and
responds to you and reacts to you in a
different way that is the reality at
least from where I am at the moment
that's like part of the reality of
changing state
in some regards that like it's beautiful
and flattering but like disconcerting as
well everyone is you just see yourself
as a same person and maybe people maybe
it's just that you've become more
confident maybe it's got nothing to do
with the position that you're in now but
yeah that's like that's something that
I'm kind of battling with at the moment
trying to work out what it means and how
to deal with it and stuff so yeah anyway
enough online solo therapy between me
and the camera next one Jimmy car so uh
Jimmy and me become friends this year
and he just has this really wonderful
idea about the difference between
trajectory and position and how
important trajectory is how much more
important it is than your position so if
you are number two in the world but last
year you were number one that is way
worse than sitting at number 150 but
being on this huge upward slope from
being number 32 months ago so number one
to number two number uh 150 from number
300 and there's a few reasons for this I
think so uh recency bias if your value
is increasing right now then it means
that you have to be popular at the
moment and by looking at recent
trajectory you are selecting for only
the people who are trendy right now
which a lot of the time is all that we
can remember we can also romanticize
where someone will be in future if
they're currently hot stuff you think
about how high this person might climb
maybe maybe they'll get to the top maybe
they'll go beyond the top
humans struggle to realize that
everything is temporary including growth
and decline instead it's easier to label
people as Heroes and losers based on
what we know of them right now so that
we don't have to predict a messy future
I was talking to this uh to Ryan long
about this he's a massive fan of Jimmy
and Ryan said there's an old saying that
there's three types of people on a
ladder one at the bottom one at the
middle and one at the top which one is
the best to be the one that's still
climbing interesting right this I don't
think it works just for status but it
works for possessions and achievements
and wealth and sex and everything else
and it's not just how we see other
people it's also how we see ourselves we
know when we're moving up or down when
life is getting better or getting worse
we have this internal like altimeter is
that what it is an altitude meter we
have one of those we know where we were
before in all of these different
domains status money possessions
achievements education competence
confidence and we know we we can predict
whether things are going up or down what
was
that Will Smith in his
biography uh gaining status is amazing
being becoming famous is amazing being
famous is a mixed bag and losing Fame is
horrible like there's just this sort of
hodg podge of lots of different things
Andrew Tate you know one of my favorite
insights that I think I've learned over
the last couple of years having things
isn't fun getting things is
fun there's something I feel like it's a
Kendrick Lamar line as well that people
don't love you when you've got something
they love you when you're on the way to
go to to getting something another way
to look at it is any accomplishment is
just a new higher bar for you to get
over in future future so let's say in
our own work that we do an episode that
hits a million plays in the first day
amazing that's a very exciting new
record that we can feel proud of almost
immediately wow that also means that
every video in future is now going to
feel unimpressive until we hit 1.1
million or more and in this way rapid
increases in status are more a curse
than a blessing and this Theory got
co-signed by Dan B Arion so you know
it's legit even though we might want our
goals and accomplishments to arrive
immediately maybe a smarter strategy is
to actually stretch out the achievement
of our dreams we shouldn't wish for
overnight success because we would then
need to be able to beat it pretty soon
or else we're going to feel like we're
declining instead slow consistent
progress is a much more reliable way to
maintain satisfaction so I came up with
this idea of slow success
strategy as a way of
making sure that you're going in the
right direction of of of of elongating
out that Journey a little bit more so
let's say that um you got a pay rise and
you were able to afford your dream car
or one of your dream cars but you're
jumping from you maybe haven't updated
your car in a very long time you have
the opportunity instead of going from
total [__] box to the ultimate car that
you've ever wanted you have the
opportunity to chunk that up maybe you
could go halfway and take a bunch of
satisfaction from that because once
you've got the dream car what is there
after that you once you've got the dream
house once you've been
on the holiday that you've always wanted
to go on if you have the opportunity of
maybe making a couple of small jumps in
between that aren't the massive leap to
the very top I think that you can
stretch out that sense of progression
and you know it's one of the reasons why
you literally should pray to never win
the lottery in some regards it would be
the most amazing and most Terri terrible
day of your life because how are you
going to have a better day than that
given the fact that trajectory is more
important than position I I absolutely
think that this is true trajectory is
more important than position and given
that what you want is to always continue
you want to just have this very nice
sort of slow steady ramp up and then you
can just flatten out toward the end of
your life what you don't want is to have
this huge Spike up and then be like all
right where do I go I'm just floating in
the stratosphere where do I go from here
and this relates to another lesson that
I learned from Adam mastriani where he
explains what happens when people
sacrifice their happiness and their
passions in order to achieve success
this such a cool uh analogy he uses here
he says this is an extra special type of
tragedy a tragedy that unfolds while
everyone cheers strangling your passions
in exchange for an elite to life is like
being on the Titanic after the iceberg
water up to your chin with everybody
telling you that you're so lucky to be
on the greatest steam ship of all time
and the Titanic is indeed so huge and
wonderful that you can't help but agree
but you're also feeling a bit cold and
wet at the moment and you're not sure
why strangling your passions in exchange
for an elite life I Lov that Insight
like what's the point in success if the
road to get there is paved with nails
and you don't care about the place that
you arrive at in the end don't forget
having things isn't fun getting things
is fun but once you have them it's not
that fun the journey is the destination
and if you strangle your passions in in
return for an elite life remembering
that when you get to the very top not
only have you got nowhere to go from
there or as you start to get to the top
the bar of increasing your trajectory
becomes harder and harder if you are
miserable you're sacrificing the thing
that you want which is happiness for the
thing which is supposed to get it which
is success and that is the bar stool
being turned upside down it's very
dangerous then I've been been on tour
with
James which has been good I've had so
much fun and I've learned an awful lot
I'm trying to not hop on about it
because I know it must be boring like I
sometimes don't like it about someone
goes on some formative experience and
all that they talk about for the next
year is this like one trip to [__]
Peru so I'm trying not to be like the
tour guy but it has been very formative
it's been very strange to watch you know
like a few thousand people over the
space of a couple of weeks come out and
see you live but while I was watching
James one of my favorite lessons that I
took from him is this idea about imagine
how good you'd be at something you loved
if you're winning at something that you
hate so committing to decisions that you
feel drawn toward making often makes you
feel nervous it's an existential pull
toward a new dire a life Direction
changing a job or leaving a relationship
or moving to a new city it's hard it's
often hard to let go of the fear around
what this new situation might might have
in store but his justification is that
you absolutely can because if you're not
happy right now you're not risking
anything in any case what's the worst
that could happen you leave a job that
you hate to take a chance on one that
you love fail and still have the one
that you hate there to go back to that's
still a success in fact it's more than a
success because you've closed the loop
that you had in your mind that was
ramping up anxiety cost for ages and
ages in the back of your mind and you
don't need to worry about it anymore and
this is the difference in life between
playing to win and playing to not lose a
more difficult decision is if your life
is okay but not perfect and this is the
region beta problem right you don't hate
your job or your relationship or your
city but they're not fulfilling you as
you thought you would how do you know
when to give up the good for the great
how do you even know what good and great
are how do you know when you're
deceiving yourself into thinking that
the grass is greener and in fact the
problem is your perspective on the
situation not the situation itself that
is messy but if you've got something
where Johnny from Johnny and USF propan
Fitness used to sing to himself on his
way to his old accounting job singing I
don't want to go to work I don't want to
go to work I don't want to go to work
just over and over again and his Ms one
day turned to him and was like I'm not
sure I'm not sure that you're fully
fulfilled it's oh you think like he
created an entire song about not a good
song but he created a song and he was
singing a song to himself about not
wanting to go to work if that's you what
are you giving up and if you're being
successful if you're being effective at
something that you do not
enjoy how great could you be if you were
fired up and you couldn't wait to hit
the the alarm on a morning so that you
could get out and go and do it so yeah
if you're succeeding at something that
you hate imagine how amazing you'd be at
something that you loved and then Philip
Lin had this idea this is from Douglas
Murray who told me about it he said uh I
felt like I'd been shun Ed to the side
of my own life often times there's a
thing we must do something we're called
or compelled to do and yet we can ignore
this sense and proceed in a different
direction not take the risk not try the
thing or make the change this is how we
shunt ourselves to the side of our own
lives by ignoring the things we feel
called to do in place of things our
fears rationalize that we should do
instead we can protect ourselves from
failing publicly by ensuring that we
fail privately even though it doesn't
seem it in the face of a big scary
decision the pain of regret hurts much
worse than the pain of failure so you
need to get out of your own way as best
you can here and that idea of being
shunted to the side of your own life
like you should have you were meant to
live a different life you weren't there
I can't remember who it was I think it
was maybe George Mack who was telling me
about how imagine that you met God at
the Pearly Gates and he said you you did
all right you did you did okay what why
did you just come with me and I can show
you what you were supposed to do this is
the life that you were supposed to live
and it was you taking the chances it was
you having the conviction to follow your
your courage and to go after the things
that you truly wanted it was you playing
to win not playing to to not
lose and that would be pain and that's
the same you know the true hell is when
the person you are meets the person you
could have been like perhaps that would
be true hell uh but yeah this this
Robert sapolsky thing as well which kind
of relates to that um Journey
destination idea but I haven't been able
to stop thinking about it hubman posted
a screenshot of it on his Instagram a
couple of weeks ago and I I just can't
stop thinking about it dopamine is not
about the pursuit of happiness it is
about the happiness of pursuit so much
of life and enjoyment is about the
anticipation of things coming in fact
the anticipation is often actually more
enjoyable than the experience Tim Ferris
used to book these
vacations years in advance so that he
would stretch out that anticipation for
so long it's basically like free holiday
before your holiday as he was excited
and thinking about it it puts a new
perspective on it's not the journey it's
the destination because there actually
is no destination each arrival at a
destination simply marks the beginning
of another journey toward the next
destination Morgan housel told me that
when he went on holiday after months of
planning you know he's got all of these
kids and organiz and he writes for
collaborative fund and he's got a fund
and he's like this big guy and his
author and he's got all of this [__]
that he needs to sort and he finally
arrives and he steps out onto the
balcony and he's there on the first
night and he looks out in the sun
setting or whatever and his first
thought was wow we should totally come
back here next year it would be great if
we came back here next year so literally
during the supposed enjoyment of the
destination Morgan was captured by the
Allure of the next journey and it's
hilarious but tragic like
the dangerous thing about anticipation
is it can cause us to look over the
shoulder of the present moment to always
see what's coming next so that we never
actually experience what's happening
right now and this has been one of the
most common questions that we've had at
the Q&A you know I I don't want to leave
growth and and achievements and
experiences and life on the table I want
to feel like I left it all on the field
of play and I maximized my time and all
the rest of it but I want my mind and my
sort of spirit to be where my feet are I
want to be able to take pride and
pleasure and gratitude and happiness and
peace in the things that I'm doing
whilst continuing to try and Achieve
like how do I how do I find this balance
and it's
been it's been really tough I I this is
something that I struggle with as well
looking over the shoulder of the present
moment to see what's coming next always
peers in my mind when something great
Great's happening and I'm always
thinking about already thinking about
whatever's going to happen next one of
the solutions I think that you can do is
to celebrate micro winds as much as
possible lots of little way markers As
you move along you know lots of tiny
little destinations put along the
journey any excuse I think to celebrate
a victory celebrate a win celebrate some
new record or or or just a degree of
satisfaction it doesn't need to be a big
celebration but I really think that that
one good way of chunking up long
destinations into shorter Journeys um
James Smith was talking about how his
clients a lot of the time will say I
want to lose 10 kilos he goes well hang
on why don't we lose one kilo and then
lose another kilo and then lose another
kilo that seems like a way that you
could celebrate the win presuming you
don't celebrate it with a massive like
3,500 calorie cake that seems like a
much more enjoyable way to go about this
but yeah I think so much of so much of
what I've been thinking about this year
and and what it seems like from the live
shows and the questions and the q&as
that you guys have too is this balance
between becoming and being
between growth and presence between
wanting to achieve as much as possible
and wanting to be grateful for the
things that we've already accomplished
like this balances is a a tough one and
if anyone's got the cheat code please
send it in next one
selfworth and why it's so tricky to get
right is again another challenge because
you're built to care about the opinions
of the people that are around you and
fully dispensing with this impulse is a
super difficult task but turning down
the volume is not only achievable but I
think also crucial Outsourcing your
sense of self-worth to the crowd is
unbelievably dangerous not only will you
begin to change how you act to fit in
with the expect expectations of everyone
else that they have of you you sometimes
lose who you really are in the process
and again this is kind of like that
first one that if you're only playing a
role you're going to basically be
marionetta by your interpretation of
what the people around you want to see
that's super dangerous Ginder bogle's
got this beautiful idea where he says
they exaggerate the more idiosyncratic
facets of their personalities becoming
crude caricatures of themselves this
caricature quickly becomes the
influencer's distinct brand and all
subsequent attempts by the influencer to
remain on brand and fulfill audience
expectations require them to act like
the caricature as the caricature becomes
more familiar than the person both to
the audience and to the influencer it
comes to be regarded by both as the only
honest expression of the influencer so
that any deviation from it soon looks
and feels inauthentic at that point the
Persona has eclipsed the person and the
audience has captured the influencer
this is the ultimate trapo in the Hall
of Fame to become a prisoner of One's
Own Persona the desire for recognition
in an increasingly atomized World L us
to be who strangers wish us to be and
with personal development so uous and
lonely there is ease and comfort in
crowdsourcing your identity but amid
such Temptations it's worth remembering
that when you become who your audience
expects at the expense of who you are
the affection you receive is not
intended for you but for the character
you're playing a character you'll
eventually Tire of and so be warned
being someone often means being fake and
if you chase the approval of others you
may in the end lose the approval of
yourself schopenhauer said other places
heads are a wretched place to be the
home of a man's true happiness and this
Outsourcing of self-worth to the crowd
this manipulation of who you are
honestly of showing up in a way that's
performative so that other people will
like you or you think that they will
means that the best you can hope for is
for people to fall in love with a
projection and ultimately what may end
up happening is that you now need to
play up to a role which you do not you
do not resonate with which it is not you
and if you start to deviate from that
even if you're not a content
creator that deviation is going to feel
disingenuous even though it is you
moving toward a more genuine version of
you so it's like audience capture is
just
so
evidently verse and easy to slip into
for exactly those reasons next one I
came up with some I thought it was a
cool idea uh the four levels of f saying
[__] you so people talk about uh [__]
you money and that was kind of the first
level it's a meme but it's also a truth
there's an amount of wealth that you can
achieve when typical restrictions and
conventions don't really apply to you
anymore you don't need to suck up to The
Gatekeepers you don't need to do things
that you don't want to do and in extreme
situations you kind of don't even need
to follow the law because you can pay
people off or buy expensive solicitors
and lawyers and stuff and then [__]
freedom is kind of Downstream from [__]
your money but can also be created aside
from it by cultivating a lack of
resilience on other groups there are no
restrictions on where you can travel to
and when and for how long you don't need
to show up to work on time or work at
all if you're sufficiently well
structured you don't really even need to
care about the state of the economy or
the power grid or The Wider world or
whatever um this is your classic Austin
guy that buys a ranch somewhere in
bassdrop or bave or whatever uh and they
now live outside of town and they don't
really even need to worry about anything
they the
the a siloed little Nation out in the
middle of nowhere and then another level
that I think you can get to again all of
these kind of exist independently it's
not like they're stacked on top of each
other uh which is significantly cheaper
and more accessible and more common and
maybe even more powerful which was the
[__] you family so a lot of fathers that
I've spoken to have told me about how
their priorities were completely changed
upon starting a family and all of the
previous status games that they used to
play seem quite Petty because the
admiration and the gamesmanship that
they used to play in order to impress
people in power or those with
status seemed Juvenile and shallow in
retrospect and much of their anxiety
about whether different people liked
them or thought they were cool or
whatever evaporate
the only person that they really needed
to care about impressing was the one 5T
asleep above them in their house and
maybe the person that was next to them
in the bed to their kids they were the
coolest richest strongest most heroic
person on the planet and this gives dads
it seems a very powerful kind of
Liberation and it seems to me that much
of what young men get up to our
surrogate activities until they finally
become a father and this isn't to say
that all fathers have become like Placid
soy boy hippies or that having kids new
is your ambition but it definitely seems
to open up a new realm where dads care
far less about the flum and Jetsam that
used to occupy their lives but then I
heard a story this weekend about a
fourth type of saying [__] you which is
[__] you Fame and this is I guess
whereas the the family and the freedom
and to some degree the money pulls you
outside of the existing uh hierarchy and
the existing game this is winning the
existing game so well that you are no
longer at the mercy of it and that is
the example that was used was uh Rachel
mccadams doesn't have social media so
you're so ubiquitous you're so welln
that your Fame carries itself and you
don't need to any longer Play The Fame
game and Rachel mccadams not having
social media embarrassingly apparently
Rachel mccadams doesn't have social
media because of how well known she was
and I had to question who's Rachel
McAdams and then realized that someone
had done a song about her I think it was
Dave on that or whatever it's called Uh
little Bobby I've ruined that whatever
the whatever that
[__] uh sitcom is that's been going
around that's got Andrew Santino in it
that's pretty funny that they did a song
about Rachel mccadams in there I think
but other than that I didn't know who
she was famous actress doesn't have
social media she's played The Fame game
to a degree where she is so high she's
now outside of it and she doesn't need
to which perhaps is why I didn't know
who she was
I wanted for a little
while to find a justification for a hosy
quote that I loved which was we're not
afraid of failing we're afraid of what
other people will say about us if we
fail
and
that it seems to make sense it seems
honest and truthful to me and it seems
accurate failing when you're on your own
doesn't matter no one really cares if
you trip over when you're in the house
apart from Pain there isn't any
embarrassing M but if you tripped over
while you were on stage in front of 500
people there would be okay so failure is
inherently to do with other people's
judgments of us not intrinsically what
that thing is itself like if you were
playing a game of keepy uppies against
the wall you might be frustrated if you
drop the ball or whatever but it's not
the same it's nowh near the same as if
other people are watching you or
scrutinizing you or you know trying to
criticize you or whatever and then Rob
Henderson brought this idea up which is
why do you feel shame when others
falsely accuse you of misconduct your
heart rate elevates your cheeks flush
your body temperature feels like it's
rising even though you didn't do
anything wrong the reason is that social
devaluation by others is sufficient to
elicit the emotion of Shame even when
there is no wrongdoing the true trigger
of Shame is negative perceptions by
others not by the self and that actually
has source for it so I really love that
idea the fact
that being accused of something that you
didn't do apart from the indignation
right and the unfairness of it the fact
that think no I didn't I didn't this is
this is this isn't true this isn't
honest on top of that why do you have
the response if it was about the thing
that you did and not the judgments of
other people around you this shouldn't
matter and yet it obviously does we're
not afraid of failing we're afraid of
what other people will say about us if
we fail now next one neediness the
definition of neediness this is Mark
Manson who again I keep forgetting about
like he's so obvious as a person in
self-development that a lot of the time
I like overlooked for a good chunk of a
good while like overlooked a lot of the
insights that he had because he's like
oh yeah yeah Mark Manson or whatever
you're trying to look for whoever the
new diamond in the rough is but Mark's
just got so many amazing insights and
this one about the definition of
neediness actually comes from his first
book models it's like from 2014 I think
it a pickup artist book kind of like
ethical pickup Artistry neediness occurs
when you place a higher priority on what
others think of you than what you think
of yourself anytime you alter your words
or behavior to fit someone else's needs
rather than your own that is needy
anytime you lie about your interests
Hobbies or background that is needy
anytime you pursue a goal to impress
others rather than fulfill yourself that
is needy whereas most people focus on
what behavior is attractive or
unattractive what determines neediness
and therefore attractiveness is the why
behind your behavior you can say the
coolest thing or do what everyone else
does but if you do it for the wrong
reason it will come off as needy and
desperate and turn people off turning
people off is definitely not optimal but
there's an even bigger price to be paid
here which is your own self-worth like
imagine a world in which you're
unanimously adored by millions but you
hate
yourself are you happy is it worth it
probably not now imagine a world in
which you're disliked by everybody but
you love
yourself not optimal but I would propose
that self-love you would ultimately be
happier because in some tost roundabout
way the reason we want validation from
others is to give us a good enough
reason to validate ourselves and if you
compromise yourself in order to gain
favor with other people you'll know even
if you think you're not keeping score
your subconscious is and this sacrifice
of the thing that we want for the thing
which is supposed to get it sacrifice
the thing we want self-worth for the
thing which is supposed to get it
validation means that we need to
prioritize ourselves and Mark's
contention in models basically the
entirety of models as a piece of advice
for male dating is neediness is the
attraction killer therefore you cannot
prioritize other people's
opinions of yourself ahead of your own
anytime you alter your words or your
behavior to fit someone else's needs
rather than your own that's needy so I
think there's a lot in that and
neediness is not really spoken about
much it's interesting cuz it's like it
was a formative powerful book and it's
sold pretty well and there's lots in it
but the modern world of dating doesn't
really talk about neediness they talk
it's been transmuted into uh attachment
Theory right oh that person's got
avoidant attachment or that person's got
anxious attachment and that person's got
secure attachment so I don't know
sometimes
I remember I went back home and I was
talking about like trying to reverse
engineer some evolutionary psychology
insight and you know about uh the
ability for men to detach their emotions
from uh having sex and women struggling
with it and all the rest of it and I you
know come up with this big long like
high futing idea about it and then my M
went yeah yeah yeah like you know Birds
catch feels I was like birds catch feels
yeah like that that's what it was so the
same thing with the neediness I wonder
how much has been layered on top of a
fundamental uh law which is neediness is
unattractive especially for men but also
from women that if you see someone who
is overly pliable and overly responsive
and doesn't seem like they've got much
else going on it seems like it's an an
immediate indicator of low value and
that's not something that you want to
have to deal with so yeah I wonder
uh how many ideas are us just
repurposing [__] that uh we all already
knew and maybe there's like a colloquial
term that probably actually even makes
more sense all right one more Alex hosi
um when we did our
episode at the start of this year the
first one we did he we used a clip from
it at the very start and it got him a
bit of bother because we put it we put
it on Instagram and taken out of context
people were quite unhappy and he
posted basically kind of a a press
release a rebuttal against it and I
really like this so this is what it is
in full if you had disadvantages I agree
with you you are right it's harder to be
successful if x happened to you replace
x with gender race birth deformity
different language different country
abuse Etc the main point the longer
conversation is that despite the
advantage you only have one choice are
you going to do about it number one take
action anyway and become proof to other
people like you your people also born
into or abused into this tragedy that
you were that they too can overcome it
number two blame and complain and to be
clear do whatever you want I support
your choice but only one of those
decisions will make you better and I
wish I could say this without getting
attacked but you know who wins by you
not being successful whoever or what
whatever you blame and [__] them or [__]
that you can lead a rebellion of one and
blame one thing that you can control
which is you in your mind redefine the
word blame as give power to and when you
do that there's only one person you're
going to want to give more power to and
that's you for everyone who's had shitty
circumstances I'm on your side your
long-term side the side that wants you
to win so do it anyways with all the
disadvantages and still tell them to
shove it and win I want to be clear
again if you had tough [__] happened to
you it sucks and it's not your fault but
now what where do we go my two cents win
anyways and prove that you can win even
when the chips are stacked against you
and you're dealt a lousy hand because we
can't get dealt a new hand we got to
play the cards we got rather than hoping
the dealer rules in our favor so again
what do you do with your shitty hand the
only thing possible you play it the best
you can and this is a nice reframe it's
a lovely reframe against the cynicism
sort of black pill external validation
or extrinsic locus of control external
locus of control thing that's been going
on which I don't like I don't like it
it's I understand that there are lots of
immutable truths about the world and
that there is a whole distribution of
people who have advantages and
disadvantages all the way along it but
ultimately despondency kind of just puts
you at the mercy of whatever is
happening to you and that doesn't seem
particularly heroic and I don't think
that you're going to look back on it and
consider that it was a life well lived
again like Alex says like you're free to
do what you want you're free to make
whatever decision or choice or approach
to completing life that it is that you
want to go through
but I think you're going to look back
with a lot more
satisfaction and
pride and you'll overcome the bitterness
and the envy that you have of whatever
the thing or the people or the situation
or the movement or the incident was that
caused you to feel negative in the first
place because you're going to know that
despite the shitty hand that you were
dealt you continue to overcome it and I
know that that seems like a more heroic
way to to look at it trying to think
about kind of what the what The Meta
theme of this year has been uh at least
based on the lessons that we've gone
through today and seems like there's
some stuff around performing not
performing uh trying to just be yourself
um finding a place that you have
something that's reliable and honest and
and and and truthful for you
to go to in hard times right that you
want people to accept you for who you
are that you want to show up in a way
that people genuinely feel like they
have a connection with you and so that
you're not just doing this like
performance so that you're not just this
dancing monkey I guess the performative
empathy toxic compassion thing a lot of
what that's talking about is kind of the
uh outward equivalent of the same as
opposed to you wanting validation it's
you just wanting to appear good when it
comes to the social group overall um but
yeah I look guys I this year has been
crazy like I can't believe the changes
and the growth and all the rest of the
stuff that's happened this year and I'm
trying to like not lose my head along
the way which
is some days it's easier than others uh
and I'm trying to be open and honest
about what I'm going through if it was
me and I was a fan of this show and
someone was going through a kind of
formative learning experience about
changes in life I would want to know so
I'm trying to avoid accusations of being
of myself or considering myself more
important than I am or getting in the
way of these interesting guests that
come on but I'm also trying to open up
about what the experience is like of
going
from very unassured person very
unconfident person to person who does a
bit of self-work and builds a little bit
of confidence but still has you know
good chunks of Need for validation and
and and fear and people pleasing
tendencies All the Way along and then
that just gets projected and magnified
out across you know a few million people
like 40 million people 50 million people
a
month it's an interesting challenge but
I appreciate you all for being here I
appreciate every single person that's
tuned in forever but especially the ones
that have joined this year there was
this Spotify stat that said
84% of the modern wisdom audience joined
us in 2023 so uh for the 16% of you or
177% of you or whatever that joined
before that thank you for sticking about
and for the ones that have joined this
year thank you as well I hope you have a
good Christmas I hope you have a good
New Year I'll see you
soon